bangers and Bernie Sanders from Vermont
let me begin by telling you a little
story about 20 years ago in the state of
Vermont the construction unions were
strong workers went out and they earned
decent wages and they had decent
benefits 20 years ago the construction
industry broke the unions today wages in
Vermont in the construction industry of
50 percent in terms of real dollars of
what they were 20 years ago that's what
it means when you have a union and
that's what it means when you don't have
a union
therefore I've just introduced the other
day sweeping labor law reform which
would make it easier for workers in this
country to come together and form unions
what we need to do is what exists in
most industrialized countries and that
is when 50% of the workers in a unit
plus one sign a card to join a union
they have a union and when a company
refuses to negotiate a first contract as
is often the case you get 45 days
binding arbitration and you got a
contract and applause is discharged in
fire or arrests those workers who are
trying to organize we impose sharp fines
on those bosses essentially the future
of this country and one of the reasons
that our standard of living is in
decline is that the union movement is in
decline we need to rebuild the Union
then we need to bring millions of
millions of workers into the unions to
negotiate good contracts for their
workers and also to have a little bit of
power here in the Congress we cannot
continue to allow a situation in which
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer and the middle class shrinks
government is supposed to work for all
the people not just the rich and the
powerful let's stand together let's
throw these guys off